I can't remember a thing
Nothing at all
I didn't understand what they did to me
When I came round they gave me drugs
When I turned 16, I cried a lot
They wanted me to dance, but I couldn't
I didn't know how to do it
Then they beat me
One girl said, 'There's no use crying
You'll never get help unless you leave'
I woke up thinking there's no point in living
If I died, at least I'd be free of this prison
Munni was offended, we'll try to persuade her
The sky is very blue,
The sunflower is very yellow
A girl looks at a red rose
Rainclouds are very black
All the colours are very beautiful
They're all different and loved
Good clients come to see me
The people who come here are very good
First, we negotiate the price
and other conditions
They give me a certain advance
payment and I get to work
They want their parents' portraits
to pray in front of at home
They're framed and used
to remember their parents
It's not like how it used to be
There was a time when things were poor
If we had one meal a day,
we couldn't afford a second
That's why, deep down,
I've always felt upset
I've always thought that if
God had made me
an adult  much earlier,
we would have long ago,
and Mum wouldn't have had to show her 'art'
My mother's performances were really great
When she was dancing or singing
nobody would look at anyone else
Come in, come in. Have a seat here
No one will film you
We understand you're married.
Come and have a seat
This is my daughter-in-law
My name is Rinki. I was born here
My grandfather's sister used to dance
Then my mother came, and after her
we all moved here, due to our circumstances
I've been doing this since I was 8
I loved to dance and sing,
so I've been performing since then
We came to this district
when I was 14 or 15-years-old
They come in and ask if there'll be a show
We say, 'Yes, come in, have a seat'
We serve them refreshments
If they want to watch a dance,
we call the musicians in
Then the girls come
If there are a couple of performers,
they'll watch the one they like
Right now the performers are in make-up
and waiting for clients
This district is known as
the city's red-light district
Everyone knows lots of young women
are ready to dance and sing
It's a place with many traditions,
which date back even to colonial times
Even back then, people
went there to watch the shows
If it's only singing and
dancing, there's no problem
There are good people here, who just sing and dance
but there also some bad people
They run dirty businesses like
prostitution and people trafficking
My name is Reshma Chand
I was born, raised and educated here
I'm a businesswomen
I own 2-3 businesses and 4-5 rental properties
The income easily covers
my spending and sustenance,
so I use some of it to help others
As I live here, I know the locals well
I hear about their pain and problems,
which means I become involved
That's why I am best placed
to do something for them.
Is Nadjma there?
Munni-bai dji!
Aleikum assalam!
Is anyone there?
Is Nadjma here? Call her
She should come
Just for two minutes
Nadjma!
Come here!
If you want to cry, come here
Put your head on my shoulder and cry
Is your heart beating fast?
Are you afraid?
Listen, when they left you in this hell,
didn't your heart tremble?
Are you in trouble now?
Where you scared in that nightmare?
Do you remember giving
birth to your child so young?
Didn't your heart tremble then?
You have brothers, sisters,
and a child of your own
Do you want to give your child an education?
Do you earn enough to do that?
I spend everything I earn
taking care of everyone
First of all, I have a mother,
4 sisters and 2 brothers
I also have 3 children,
a son who isn't here now, and my sister's son.
My dad was in a bad way
There was no one at home
Mum did side jobs
She had no time to do
all the necessary chores
Dad had untreatable asthma
I was 13 when he died
We've been doing this job ever since
A friend promised we'd be paid
if we danced
As we were desperate for money,
we started dancing and singing
We live on Shukla Road,
a 'professional street'
You find many prostitutes here
They end up here for many reasons
Some have been sold and forced into it,
others are locals who inherited
the trade from their mothers
They all have one thing in common:
they do it because they're in need
My boat is spinning like a bee.
Why are you swimming so deep?
You're the only one in my life.
What did I do wrong?
Why are you rejecting me?
Life or death, oh, mother!
It's bad to cause people pain
Let's sing together
Ok. Who's next?
- It's your turn!
- No, not me
Yes, it is. Sing something short
Women stay here for a minimum of 3 months
We provide food, board and
other necessary provisions
The women who come here
suffer from family problems
We also protect victims of
domestic violence
Here they are safe
These women have been through a lot
Once I dreamt someone was beating me
I woke up and there was no one there
It was probably because I was constantly beaten
Chandni was brought to us by the police
She was very depressed and
afraid when the police left,
as she didn't know what this place was
She was afraid of something bad happening to her
She spent 2 days here and was very down
After two or three counselling sessions
she gradually began to speak
My parents both had heart problems
They left me with a woman
and told me to live there
They told me to ask her
to feed me if I was hungry
When she was 8,
her family decided their
neighbours should raise her
She went to live with them,
and washed their clothes and their dishes
They sold me to other people,
who sent me elsewhere
I ran away and met a girl, Sweetie
She said, 'Neither of us have anyone
I'll get you a job,
so work hard and keep studying'
She didn't let go of me and
she fed me on the way to Suvali
There, she sold me to Harkishta
In the Harkishta, illegal activities
go on behind the blinds
- What happened to you?
- They did dirty things to me
I ran away from there many times too
I was sold two or three times
- What happened exactly?
- I was beaten
They cut me here
Later, when I was brought to Punevas,
they really tried to make me
do dirty things, but I wouldn't
I said, 'Kill me, but I won't do it'
Then they beat me, 3-4 people every day
Later, I ran away from there too
Very dirty business was going on there
What exactly were their demands?
Sex
The only answer was to run away
Let's shout, 'Shiva's beating a drum!'
Our God Shiva is our defender!
Participants, please come
and take a festive treat!
And let's all cry out,
'All hail Rama!
All hail Hanuman!'
A dancing party would be organised
for all the young girls
who had reached maturity
They wouldn't know how
many girls there would be
The temple's main priests would then
select girls to become 'devadasi'
They simply proclaimed girls 'devadasi'
meaning they would satisfy
the gods' sexual desires
So the priests did what they
pleased to them on behalf of the gods
As the girls slept in the temple,
any priest could come and take one
That's the horrible life these girls had
When the British came,
they ended this horrible system
But what were the girls to do?
They had to earn a living,
so the system was transformed into a business
Dancing and singing became their business
Before, they weren't paid
by those who used them,
now they all take money
It's simply a cultural tradition
that became a business
It's good to study in this school
She began her education aged
4, and is now in first grade
She passes her tests
She's learning English, Hindi and maths
She studies well
She'll finish school,
find a good job and work well
This is my dream and plan for the future
Why are you using only one finger? Use five
Like this?
Use your fingertips instead of one finger
- Like this.
- Open your palm
If you eat with one finger, I'll cut it
It's about reputation
My daughter's ashamed
to be from this community
People know what kind
of people are around her
She asks who her father is
Where would I find his name?
No one openly calls herself a prostitute
Any children that result
can't bear the man's name,
but, naturally, every girl has her man
- How many clients do you have?
- Just the one. He's a local
He is local. He owns a store where I did my shopping
He has two children, a son and daughter
I don't want to be a home-wrecker
I'm happy with him here,
I don't need his house
Even if I went to his house, I'd still be branded.
But he'll lose his reputation.
He has a wife...He is married, has kids
There's a saying,
'People prefer street pilaf to homemade'
I'm his street pilaf
This is a drawing of my mother
I felt the urge, so I'm doing it
I'll make a portrait, paint it, prepare it
It will take some time
Nothing compares to your mum
There's her, and there's everything else
Listen, the people here are desperate
They're stuck in this horrible place
Getting out, by finding a job for example,
would solve their problems
As soon as they find another
source of income,
they won't want to return
to this accursed swamp
Destitution is why they are still here
- I don't want tea!
- Why don't you?
Gimme, gimme!
- It's 2 rupees
- No, it's 5
Go buy something
As I said, a sex worker who
doesn't have relatives employs
a babysitter who looks after
her child while she's working
Not everyone has the money,
so I opened a kindergarten for children
whose mothers can't afford a babysitter
The children here receive some education
Three little birds...
...were eating a pomegranate
One flew away...
Two are here to stay!
I'd like there to be a child care centre
where we could look after
kids from 9 am. to 9 pm
We could also teach the main
subjects and sports for free
And...
depending on their favourite hobby,
singing, dancing or music
I'm eager to help those in need of education
I also like dancing very much
Not vulgar, half-naked
dancing, of course,
but the classical forms
such as Kathak and others
It's classical dance that I'm interested in
I'm paying for everything
I bear all the expenses.
And I don't refuse anybody if they ask for help.
I'd like to help the locals,
those who wallow in dirt
and vice, to live normal lives
It depends on the woman
They talk with clients and
go with them if they want
If a woman is pretty, it's 3-5 thousand rupees
My friend told me that I wouldn't
get anywhere if I did nothing
My dad was ill and the
situation was desperate. So I did it
I didn't want to do it, but...
What don't you want?
To sell my body, to dance
and sing. It's all so dirty
The men are often drunk
No surprise in it. That's the business
I'd need support to be able to quit
Oh my sunshine! My beauty!
Wake up, baby, wake up!
My sunshine, come on, wake up!
How long will you sleep, baby?
Is it true that you're pregnant?
Yes
- Who's the father?
- Kankhaya.
- Where does he live?
- He has a house in Suboli, Pipalkoti
But he's married, so...
My parents have never wondered...
where their daughter is.
If they knew I was in that district,
they'd never talk tome
I want to get on my feet
I don't want to be a slave
and I don't want to marry
I want to be independent
I hope to God I get my children an education
I want to send them to a good school,
then I'll have my own house,
and quit dancing and singing
My family will live alone
Maybe I'll open a small shop to earn a living.
That's it